hello today we are going to talk about
decision trees and random forest
decision tree is a type of a
classification algorithm
each decision tree is created by rules
binary means the branch that can be
either yes or no and if the expression
of a gene is higher than x the classes
will separate
for example in the figure here you can
see that the luminance class can be
separated from all the other classes
based on the gene
e n s g triple zero triple zero 1 6 2 9.
this rest of the samples are further
divided into the other classes based on
other genes that are separating this
group into cloud and low normal like and
basic classes the algorithm will
continue to run until it has effectively
separated all the samples into some
group
if we use less genes in the training
data set we will get different results
because the data set can be dealt with
differently based on available features
in the second example of a binary
decision tree for breast cancer gene
expression table we see the data is
separated into three groups luminal
basal and cloudine low with only two
genes
binary decision trees are initiated in a
random start so the genes selected in
the procedure can change from time to
time
to try running decision tree pipeline on
the server select the supervised
learning section and area of analysis
where you are going to upload the
training and the test data and select
the decision trees button in the
pipeline builder
so let's get started
upload your data
and now
once the upload is finished select your
train
and test data
now click on start
and click on decision tree
now end your pipeline give a name to
your pipeline
and
stay updated with the status of your
pipeline timely by checking the
pipelines
in the results you will see the
prediction for test set and a pdf with
the decision tree visualization
also you would obtain a confusion matrix
that reveals an issue that the algorithm
ran into cloud and low was identified
four times as cloud and low and three
times as normal like that's the
confusion
if we look at the expression of these
genes we will see that they in fact do
look confusing the first gene is fairly
good luminal samples have a consistently
higher expression than the rest of the
samples for this gene
but for the second gene it is not a good
classifier
to learn more about decision trees and
tandem forest and how they work what are
the algorithms and what other results
that you are going to obtain and how do
you interpret it
visit
lesson number 14 of transcriptomics
course on
learn.amixlogic.com portal